hey guys i'm abby Sharpe welcome to
another edition of fertility files here
on Abby's kitchen today we'll be talking
about a topic that we all love to hate
our period and guys before you click
next you might actually learn something
about the women in your life so I do
encourage you to maybe stick around now
real talk friends women of childbearing
age are no stranger to the cramps
cravings and mood swings
that come with the dreaded time of the
month I've received a lot of questions
about this so today I'm gonna be
breaking down the research on the best
things to eat during each phase of your
cycle so that we can all feel our best
now before we get into it of course my
general disclaimer that the information
in this video is for education and
entertainment purposes only and you
should always speak to a registered
dietitian or your health care provider
about your unique case ok so let's get
into it by starting with the first phase
of the menstrual cycle the follicular
phase day 1 of the cycle is marked by
the arrival of our favorite red frenemy
our monthly period now this phase
involves the shedding of the uterine
lining and depending on your cycle this
may last for approximately 3 to 6 days I
think we can all agree that we aren't
feeling too hot during this phase aside
from the sexy crime scene in our pants
we typically feel super tired sluggish
and experience painful cramps that make
us want to call in sick and chill in the
field position for the day and who
exactly is to blame for all of these
emotional and physical changes are
fluctuating hormones of course at this
stage of our cycle the hormones
progesterone and estrogen are at their
lowest which explains the low energy and
overall sluggishness that women tend to
experience so what can we do from a
nutritional standpoint to ease the
effects of this face tip number one up
that iron iron is a really important
mineral that helps produce red blood
cells and transports oxygen throughout
the body because of menstrual blood
losses iron deficiency is one of the
most common nutritional deficiencies
among women of childbearing age lower
iron levels during menstruation also
explains why women typically have low
energy and fatigue
therefore women must compensate for the
amount of blood being lost from their
period by eating more iron rich foods
during this time so iron rich animal
sources include foods like red beet
poultry and fish and plant-based sources
include fortified cereals tofu beans
lentils and other legumes tip number two
pair it with vitamin C vitamin C is an
antioxidant that not only helps with
immunity healthy skin and wound healing
but also helps our bodies to absorb iron
even better think of vitamin C as iron's
trusty sidekick or cheerleader that
brings out the best in them so if you're
adding an iron rich meal during that
time of the month
make sure to pair it with a source of
vitamin C like citrus fruits or veggies
like bell peppers tomatoes or leafy
greens to give you an example this could
look as easy as a bowl of veggie chili
with a squeeze of lime juice on top or
tofu stir-fry with bell peppers it's
actually an intuitive pairing because
these foods just kind of taste good
together and it just proves how smart
the body truly is tip number three go
decaf just as vitamin C helps to
increase the absorption of iron there
are also certain inhibitors to be aware
of that can interfere with iron
absorption coffee and caffeinated teas
such as green tea and black tea have an
antioxidant substance called polyphenols
which can decrease the amount of iron
the body absorbs the other potential
downside to caffeine is that it's a
vasoconstrictor which means it makes the
blood vessels in your body constrict a
lot of women find that this constriction
can make their period cramps even worse
so for that reason it might be best to
stick to herbal tea on those first few
days or at the very least spread the
caffeine out at least an hour before or
after your iron rich meal to help
maximize the absorption of iron tip
number four get plant powered a lot of
women find that their cramps in these
early days of this phase so debilitating
that they have a really hard time
enjoying a full meal this is also the
time when our bloating and cramps start
so making sure to stay nourished with
lighter less processed food
may help while salt and fat are both
super delicious
you probably apparently know that this
isn't probably going to make you feel so
great right now because we're already
feeling so bloated sluggish and sick
salt increases water attention which
causes bloating and fatty foods increase
prostaglandin production which can
increase contractions aka cramps so I
would really try to focus on recipes
with lots of veggies and fruit
especially those that are rich and
hydrating water and energizing carbs to
help with your waning energy levels plus
a little bit of some whole grains and
legumes meals in this phase do not need
to be fancy or Instagram a bowl I mean
you're probably really tired and just
feel like crap so be kind to yourself
and focus on super simple meals with
whole ingredients whenever you can tip 5
take a walk okay so during those first
few days of your period and the days
that follow your estrogen and
progesterone levels are pretty low so
your stamina might not be so great but
there is some evidence that a little
light gentle exercise may play a
therapeutic role in relieving cramps by
releasing endorphins which helps improve
your mood and relax the body exercise
may also provide a distraction from the
discomfort of the cramps so that also is
always a good thing this may or may not
be helpful for everyone depending on the
severity of your cramps but it doesn't
hurt to try okay let's jump into Phase
two of the menstrual cycle ovulation now
at this face a new egg begins the
process of preparing its descent down
the fallopian tubes to enter the uterus
in hopes of meeting a nice little sperm
to settle down with this phase is met
with an increase in estrogen
testosterone follicle stimulating
hormone and luteinizing hormone which
explains why we feel more energized at
this point so take advantage of this
increase in libido sexual energy and
mood now is your time to work tip one
move in a way that feels good because
your energy levels are now a lot more
balanced in this phase you're probably
feeling more excited to hit the gym so
hit up some Pilates weight training spin
class or what I guess evolution
would want us to be doing of course
having sex our higher energy levels and
brighter mood are a good match for these
types of moderate to high intensity
activities so if you are an active
person and this brings you joy now is
the time for it tip number two use this
energy to prep again because this phase
allows for optimal energy levels this is
the best time to get in the kitchen and
cook up a storm
so get at your slow-cooker instant pot
and every casserole dish you own this is
when you want to do your batch prepping
for the week so chopping up vegetables
cooking proteins making fries soups and
casseroles for the week go get'em girl
now let's talk about the third and final
phase of the menstrual cycle the luteal
phase the luteal phase happens when
ovulation phase does not result in
fertilization aka
there ain't no bun in the oven when this
happens hormone levels decline and we
experience the oh so lovely PMS this may
include symptoms like cramps headaches
bloating mood swings fatigue and food
cravings which brings me to tip number
one notice your food cravings now we
have all been there you know eating
chocolate chip cookies and crying over a
cheesy rom-com for no real reason that
my friends is the luteal phase aka when
PMS hits but food cravings symptoms are
actually scientifically proven research
has found our food cravings during the
luteal phase are linked to the amount of
leptin in our blood leptin is the hunger
hormone that tells us when we're full
and we can stop eating studies have
actually shown that there may be a
relationship between leptin and estrogen
hormones and the food cravings that we
experience when leptin and estrogen
levels are high during the luteal phase
women tend to experience increased
cravings particularly for sweet carb
rich foods however when leptin and
estrogen levels are low women may
experience fewer cravings now we may not
be able to change our leptin or estrogen
levels but what we can do is listen to
our bodies and notice our cravings and
any patterns that arise during this
phase of menstruation
do you crave sweet foods or salty foods
are there certain textures that you
prefer maybe a satisfying crunch from a
bag of chips or the soft dough eNOS from
a doughnut I mean it's really important
we start to become more aware and
mindful of these food cravings in order
to assess what it is that your body
actually needs and that brings me to tip
number two let yourself have the carbs
as mentioned research suggests that we
tend to crave refined carbs during this
phase thanks to PMS and trust me I am
all for enjoying that cookie or bowl of
chocolate ice cream but this is a
long-ass phase of our cycle and when
we're about to lead ourselves into an
even more sluggish phase aka
our period right after I figure it's
ideal to have some really good fuel on
board also restricting all the carbs
right when you're craving them the most
is just going to kick off a massive
cookie binge and that is just not gonna
leave us feeling too hot either now is
the time to focus on slow burning but
delicious carbs maybe make a big batch
of overnight oats for breakfast pick up
a hearty CD bread for lunch or roast
some sweet potatoes with a little bit of
maple syrup and cinnamon for dinner and
when in doubt pair that car with a
source of protein and fat to keep those
blood sugar levels even keeled tip
number three up the fiber on a similar
note let's talk about fiber progesterone
levels are at an all-time high during
this phase right before your period and
we know that progesterone is one of the
major culprits of constipation so you're
gonna want to sneak in lots of fiber
rich whole grains like quinoa or bran
cereal things like berries or vegetables
like broccoli or kale flax beans and
nuts that brings me to tip number four
ease the bloat during the luteal phase
of menstruation and leading it to those
first few days of our period it's very
common feel bloated regardless of how
much or what you eat thanks to our
higher levels of estrogen and those
estrogen levels cause us to retain more
water therefore as I mentioned earlier
with the menstrual phase you'll want to
focus on more fresh foods instead of
highly processed salty foods you might
also want to
to plain water as carbonated drinks can
cause more gas and discomfort plus going
easy on foods that tend to cause you
digestive distress this obviously varies
from person to person but common
triggers are - mat foods like dairy
apples wheat and beans gassy veggies
like broccoli and kale sugar alcohols
and booze if you do have a higher sodium
meal and are feeling a little bit
uncomfortable don't sweat it
I mean you can pair it with foods that
are rich in water like cucumber lettuce
and citrus or potassium rich foods like
bananas and sweet potatoes to help
balance out the salt bottom-line us
ladies deal with our monthly period
every month so we are totally experts
right now in fact you're probably doing
a lot of these things without even
thinking about them because they
intuitively just feel good but if you're
finding some of your symptoms at
different times of the month totally
throwing you off I hope this video gives
you some evidence-based ideas on how you
can feel your best no matter what your
hormones throughout you well folks that
is all for today as always if you like
this video be sure to give it a thumbs
up leave me a comment below if you have
any fertility reproductive or hormonal
health questions subscribe to the
channel and I'll see you next time on
Abby's kitchen bye
[Music]